[Music]
they are the two computer whiz kids who
changed the world as we know it larry
and sergey always had this kind of
irreverence as part of their attitude
which is what made them so creative
these two founders really think of
themselves as noblemen they think that
what they're doing is good for the world
[Music]
larry page and sergey brin were the kind
of guys who kept bill gates up at night
journalist caneletta
i said mr gates what is your nightmare
and i thought he would say apple or
netscape or oracle and he said i'll tell
you what i worry about
i worry about some guy in a garage
inventing a new technology microsoft has
never thought about
well in 98 two guys were in a garage and
the hand lettered sign and it said
google worldwide headquarters
in an industry where innovation is just
part of the job description larry page
and sergey brin have become virtual
masters of the universe of information
gathering
what we don't know
we google 629
000 results wow
and all this time i thought googling
yourself meant the other thing
not anymore
silicon valley is littered with startups
that have stalled out
why these two computer science geeks
succeeded may have a lot to do with the
nearly parallel lives they led before
creating together one of the world's
largest and most powerful companies
brynn and page respectfully declined to
participate in this program
sergey brin was born in the soviet union
in 1973
his parents were mathematicians and
jewish which limited their career
opportunities
mark malcid is the co-author of the
google story so sergey's father went to
a conference in warsaw
met a whole bunch of colleagues from the
west saw what life was like outside the
soviet union came back sat the family
down and said we have to leave
his parents brought with them a sense of
purpose they instilled in their son
it boiled down to a simple message
don't come back with a b don't come back
with the second place award make it
first always and sergey internalized
this and it did form a core part of his
personality
like brynn larry page was born in 1973
his family lived in michigan and his
father was the first person in his
family to get a college degree
both of his parents were in similar
fields as brins
they were second generation computer
science which at that time was very
unusual because computer science was
really only developing as a field in the
60s and here both of their parents
were advanced degrees
they see themselves as on a mission and
that mission
it really does spring from their
biographies
in 2009 page shared that mission with
the graduating class at the university
of michigan
you know what it's like to wake up in
the middle of the night with a vivid
dream
and you know how if you don't have a
pencil and pad by the bed
it will be completely gone by the next
morning i had one of those dreams when i
was 23.
when i suddenly woke up i was thinking
what if we could download the whole web
and just keep the links and i grabbed a
pen and started writing
soon after i told my advisor terry
winograd it would take a couple of weeks
for me to download the web he nodded
knowingly fully aware it would take much
longer but wise enough not to tell me
stanford professor and engineering
consultant to google terry winograd
larry just thinks of ways of doing
things that you might not expect sergey
was a lot like larry he also was someone
who
really wanted to think outside the box
to say if that sounds like it's
impossible let's try it
it was 1995 at stanford university when
the headstrong overachievers first met
one of their stanford professors used to
say well the difference between the two
of them was that sergey would just burst
into my office without asking larry
would knock and then burst in
[Music]
in the 90s searching the internet was
rudimentary hit or miss
often returning results that were
useless
and the process was very slow
then you typed in your query
you did something else while you waited
for it to get the results then you went
back and looked at the results and most
of them were completely irrelevant paige
and brynn pushed for something better
sergey's big interest was in taking all
the pages on the world wide web and
trying to make sense of it trying to
find patterns they started to do a
record of backlinks they called them
page noticed that behind every web page
there were hundreds or even thousands of
other pages that linked to it
[Music]
it was a eureka moment that would change
the so-called information age
then they realized that that list of
backlinks could be used for ranking
if you have more backlinks it showed you
a better page
[Music]
if a lot of other websites linked to a
web page that probably meant users
thought it was good
the genius was in recognizing that this
kind of algorithm could give you the
kind of results that mattered the most
to searchers page and brynn had their
secret formula now it needed a name the
guys were looking for a great name that
was going to capture the grandiose
vision that they had and hit upon this
giant number
one with a hundred zeros after it
commonly known as google
g-o-o-g-o
they discovered it was owned they said
you know what let's put a friendlier
spelling on it
on september 15 1997 they registered
google as a website
and paige and brynn dropped out of their
phd programs to focus on attracting
funding for their young company it
wouldn't be easy
investors like ram sharam were skeptical
there were five search engines at the
time and so i said maybe any one of them
might be interested in the technology
the world didn't need a sixth search
engine
[Music]
google just didn't fit into the
conventional wisdom of what a website
should do which was to keep users from
migrating to another page
google did the unthinkable it helped
users explore the wider web
larry page and sergey brin had a
different attitude they said we don't
want a portal we want to get the search
results to them in a split second
so one sunday morning larry and sergey
were sitting on the porch of a stanford
professor friend of theirs and andy
bechtelsheim one of the founders of sun
microsystems pulls up in his sports car
walks up gets about a 10 minute demo
says
this is fantastic this is the next big
big thing and writes a check on the spot
for a hundred thousand dollars made out
to google inc
steven levy is senior writer of wired
magazine this is the way things work in
silicon valley you know it it sounds
astounding that someone would just write
a 100 000 check and get you going but
you have to realize that there was a
hidden pedigree to this they were at
stanford their professors had done this
before this is a pretty good bet we
might lose our hundred thousand dollars
but we could win big there and at the
time we had no company at all
and in fact we couldn't cash the check
just by the way with no legal documents
you know none of that stuff
and even though they had the seed money
they still needed much more cash
no one was buying into google
they went back to ramsharam
they found three other investors and
together we raised enough money to get
them off the ground
enough money was one million dollars
including 250 thousand dollars from jeff
bezos of amazon.com
paige and brynn incorporated google on
september 4th 1998 and they moved into
one of those storied garages in menlo
park
they attracted the attention of two
well-known silicon valley venture
capitalists michael moritz of sequoia
capital and john doerr of kleiner
perkins
both wanted an exclusive deal
brennan page said no deal they had the
presence of mine at their tender asia in
their mid-20s then
to say we won't take money from only one
venture capitalist we want to assure
that neither one of them has control so
we're going to split it
in june of 1999 google issued its first
press release announcing the investment
25 million dollars
brennan page now needed to hire
first-rate engineers people who would
meet their exacting standards chris
sacca is a former googler it was one of
the most intense hiring processes of any
company in the world i had somewhere
between 12 and 15 interviews over just a
couple days
they created a headquarters they called
the googleplex offering employee
services like free food and child care
and developed the informal company motto
of don't be evil
but google still wasn't making money
larry would come in and i would say well
how are you going to make money from
this
google co-founders larry page and sergey
brin had created a new search engine but
had yet to find a way to turn it into
profit they didn't like the idea of
using advertising to cash in
at first they thought advertising was
grubby commercial kind of unseemly
they are famously sparse homepage was
originally designed by sergey brin
unlike rivals yahoo and aol paige and
bryn refused to clutter their home page
with ads
we won't take any ads on the homepage
because we think to build of trust we
want to not feel like we're bogging them
down with advertisements yet no ads at
all meant no revenue
paige and brynn had to accept
advertising as their only option there
were search engines in the early days
which when you rent a page the first few
things which looked just like regular
search results happened to be things
that the sponsors of those had paid the
search engine to put there and they said
that's not good for users i don't want
the things that somebody else wants me
to see i want the things that i want to
see
then they found a compromise they could
live with
they invented a new way of targeting
text ads triggered by search requests
instead of distracting pop-ups or
flashing ads these small ads were placed
above and next to search results
it's familiar now but revolutionary back
then
they called it google adwords
businesses big and small could take
control of their advertising dollars by
purchasing ads key to certain words
david thacker was a project manager on
adwords advertisers love the system
because they only pay when someone
actually clicks on their ad for many
advertisers it's the most efficient form
of marketing they ever have
for businesses it was the holy grail a
direct connection to their best
customers
with a massive new revenue source google
exploded
by september of 2000 it had indexed a
billion urls and was available in 15
languages
still with all of google's success few
people outside silicon valley knew who
had created it
sergey brin went on to tell the truth
and fooled the judges
sergey brin please stand up
[Applause]
but media moguls knew exactly who they
were
barry diller was one of the first
traditional media executives to visit
google guys
larry is sitting there with his pda his
little handheld device and he's looking
down and doing his email
and he says larry please i'm talking to
you can we just converse
and he says i can do both mary dylan
says no you can't do both choose he says
i choose this
with tremendous growth came other
challenging issues for the search giant
google
the venture capitalists behind the
company michael moritz and john doerr
were pressuring its co-founders to hire
a ceo
they were resistant but they didn't want
to say you know we can do it but they
thought they could do it they went
through 12 13 14 interviews they didn't
like any of the people they they saw
they visited steve jobs just to
meet him because he was a hero of theirs
and they said to john dora after the
meeting why can't he be our ceo john
doerr introduced paige and bryn to eric
schmidt a businessman with an
engineering background
you just hired eric schmidt he's come
over to run google
yes so what what's the idea behind that
i mean you guys couldn't run it yourself
parental supervision
to be honest you know eric is a grown up
in in the room i mean he's he's in his
mid 50s not mid 30s he's got a lot of
experience he's more of a diplomat than
they are and that's needed in dealing
with the
traditional media world which they
increasingly bump me up against
by the end of 2001 eric schmidt was
google ceo
page became president of products and
bryn the president of technology
the two founders still shared an office
they have a mind meld they anticipate
each other's words they back each other
up there's no sense of
tension between them it's one of the
great strengths
of that company
with eric schmidt in place google kept
up its spectacular growth
while its rivals slowly faded away
the search engine linked to 3 billion
web pages and forged a partnership with
aol which brought them 34 million new
customers you had this incredibly
profitable company how are you going to
get into the next level how are you
going to
provide the kind of capital growth that
they needed
the solution
it was time for google to go public
being unconventional they decided that
they were going to hold an ipo unlike
any that wall street had ever seen they
were going to set the price via an
auction
to determine and try to extract their
greatest value from the stock
the stock price on august 19 2004 closed
at just over 100 a share making the
company worth more than 23 billion
the two founders became billionaires
soon the company expanded with google
maps google news and google earth
their idealism and bold ideas had built
their reputation but the company was
stumbling with their free email service
gmail was a great product that was
really poorly launched
when users saw ads pop up that were
directly related to their personal
emails alarms went off when people first
saw these ads they were shocked because
they thought how could these ads be so
targeted you know i'm reading this this
email about uh you know my friend's
vacation to hawaii i'm getting ads about
hawaii is somebody snooping into my
email
the concern around gmail launched a much
deeper fundamental argument about
privacy and trust
do you know how google's using all the
information it collects on you all of
the web searches that i've done for
years and years
all of the emails that i've done
potentially information about health
records information about the books that
i'm looking at information about where
i'm going because i'm typing it into
google maps
in a sense
they're the big brother that we've been
talking about all these years
the ultimate big brother was about to
put their don't be evil philosophy to
the test
in 2006 google reached an agreement with
china for access to their 400 million
web users with one condition
they censor search results of banned
topics
for bryn son of russian immigrants it
was a troubling decision at google's
friday meeting sergey spoke with passion
about growing up in the soviet union and
how his parents literally escaped the
soviet union to come to america and what
that meant to him and that dialogue
happened including everybody they wanted
to hear from all the employees there
sergey swallowed hard but they all said
at google this is the biggest consumer
market in the world we have to be here
google agreed to chinese demands i know
there was a lot of controversy
surrounding that and we had to self
censor
a fair amount but we were actually able
to censor less and less and our local
competitors there also censored less and
less
so i feel like our entry
made a big difference
but things started going downhill
google discovered a cyber attack on
their systems
the more troubling thing to me is that
we discovered the motivation
which we believed to be to gain access
to gmail accounts in particular for
chinese human rights activists
google pulled the plug and redirected
users to an unfiltered site in hong kong
that isn't subject to censorship
leave britney spears alone right
now
youtube began as a place for people to
share home videos
it soon grew into one of the world's top
search engines
by july 2006 users were uploading 65 000
videos a day and google wanted in
they went out and acquired youtube for
1.65 billion dollars in google stock
youtube founders chad hurley and steve
chen were thrilled today we have some
exciting news for you we've
been acquired by google yeah thanks
in 2006 google ceo eric schmidt
acknowledged that to stay competitive
the company also had to enter the world
of mobile phones
in fact a year earlier they had quietly
bought another startup android a small
company with software for cell phones
there's so many more mobile phones than
personal computers as people do more and
more searches on mobile phones it should
eventually balance out again this would
be many years
it didn't take years
apple's phenomenal success with the
iphone in 2007 set a collision course
between the two companies
months later brennan paige announced
their android operating system would run
on a variety of mobile phones
their longtime idol steve jobs slammed
google for entering the phone business
and accused them of trying to kill the
iphone
at the google developer conference in
may of 2010 google's vice president of
engineering tore into apple
if google did not act
we faced a draconian future
a future where one man
one company one device one carrier would
be our only choice
that's a future we don't want
and google is battling with another
giant in the tech world they bump up
against microsoft in so many ways
they have a browser chrome microsoft has
internet explorer google also acquired
companies that dealt with online
versions of word processing software and
spreadsheets things that directly go
after microsoft jugular with their
office product
microsoft fired back with its own search
engine bing which debuted in spring of
2009. can i ask what you make of bing do
you like it
um
i think uh
you a bing user
uh oh yeah no no i
i use i use all search engines out there
uh i think that what bing has reminded
us uh
uh is that the search is a very
competitive market
bing ironically offered google
protection by letting them dodge
accusations of being a monopoly
bill gates said this is the company that
is closest to us as a competitor they
are just as hungry and as
ruthless he didn't use that word but i
am as we are there is a danger they make
a lot of enemies it's a blind spot
because
these two founders
really think of themselves as noblemen
they think that what they're doing is
good for the world they've always
enjoyed
feeling like the underdog feeling like
the evil empire was microsoft and now
they've discovered that and some people
think they're the evil empire
their own slogan do no evil was suddenly
being used against them
google's quest on the road to organize
the world's information took a new turn
call it a detour with an ambitious
feature they called street view an
attempt to photograph every neighborhood
on the planet
it would eventually include ordinary
images from main street to extraordinary
views of antarctica
but the effort also took private user
information from unsecured wi-fi
locations
many people felt their privacy had been
compromised
google acknowledged the mistake and
agreed to destroy data
the company known for search was
struggling to diversify and was facing
an aggressive new challenger mark
zuckerberg
facebook's one billion users spend more
time on the social network posting
valuable information that is invisible
to google's search engine
information that all advertisers chase
so far google's efforts at social
networking have failed but its founders
are keenly aware that as users habits on
the web change google will have to make
a lot more friends
in january 2011 in a startling silicon
valley shakeup eric schmidt announced
that google was simplifying its
management structure and that larry page
was ready to lead and would take over
from him as ceo
co-founder sergey brin will focus on new
products
schmidt tweeted day-to-day adult
supervision no longer needed in 14 years
google grew from startup to technology
giant hitting 50 billion dollars in
revenue in 2012.
in the space of a year larry page and
sergey brin both got married
paige married stanford bioinformatics
phd lucinda southworth in december 2007
on richard branson's island branson was
also his best man
brynn married biotech specialist ann
wojitsky in the bahamas with his partner
larry page standing up for him they both
have two children
[Music]
google.org its philanthropic arm has
contributed over 100 million dollars to
various organizations from clean energy
to global health
larry page and sergey brin have changed
the way we get information it's been a a
great experience for me to see them grow
over the last 12 years that i've known
them
i feel extremely proud of what they've
accomplished
larry and sergey always had this kind of
irreverence as part of their attitude
which is what made them so creative it's
great
i think google attracts people who care
who care about users who care about
their fellow human who care about the
planet and just can't sit still
they built a company that absolutely
changed the world
[Music]
[Applause]
mark zuckerberg was a harvard freshman
with a gift for computer programming
less than a decade later he is the
baby-faced multi-billionaire power
broker who rubs shoulders with the
president my name is barack obama and
i'm the guy who got mark to wear a
jacket and tie i think most people still
haven't really digested the scale of
facebook or how quickly it's grown the
goal is obviously to get to ubiquity i
mean mark zuckerberg wants everyone to
be on this service he transformed the
dorm room project into the internet's
biggest global village the site now has
over 900 million users i can't
underestimate how driven mark zuckerberg
really is zuckerberg is just as
visionary as steve jobs
he's going to prove just as influential
as bill gates
but for all that success zuckerberg has
confronted bitter battles and lawsuits
over facebook's origins one he wanted to
control his own thing and two if he's
gonna go against someone he's gonna
crush them
we spent three months working with mark
being essentially let on we were all
blindsided we had no idea that you know
he was working on a competing product he
has waged an all-out war on his biggest
competitors facebook and google's
relationship is pretty simple they just
don't like each other and zuckerberg has
come under fire for pushing the limits
on user privacy users have less control
over private information they don't
fully know how their information is
being shared he's not dealing with just
a piece of technology
he's dealing with people
and their behavior and in many ways he's
doing it on the fly
they have amassed this humongous
database of information about us because
we trusted them
so the question is should we still trust
them
[Music]
i think that the goal that we went into
it with
wasn't to make an online community but
sort of like a mirror for the real
community that existed in real life
mark zuckerberg we think we know him
because we've seen his life unfold in
the oscar-winning movie the social
network the portrait was unsparing a
super geek intense cut throat brilliant
and socially crippled i don't understand
which part but was it accurate he's
always had friends you know he's a
pretty social guy
um i think the last time i checked 879
friends on facebook
this is the real mark zuckerberg in
rarely seen footage shot at facebook's
first corporate headquarters by young
filmmakers in 2005.
what are we celebrating we've got three
million users three million users yeah
and how long has facebook been around
not that long
a little more than a year
while zuckerberg pushes the envelope on
user privacy he opted out of
participating in this program
in 2004 at the age of 19 he created
facebook today the 28 year old ceo has
accumulated a net worth estimated at
15.5 billion dollars mark's mission from
the beginning was about connecting
people and it was clearly based on this
theory that if the world were more
connected it would be a better place but
there's a lot of surprises when you
really dig deep into the story of
facebook the biggest single surprise is
the
peculiar and tenacious personality of
mark zuckerberg and you know the depth
of his convictions and his consistency
[Music]
born in 1984 he grew up in the hudson
river town of dobbs ferry a bedroom
community north of new york city
david kirkpatrick spent two years
researching a book about zuckerberg and
facebook called the facebook effect he
comes from an unbelievably supportive
family in which he's the only son and he
has three sisters so he was kind of the
prince and in fact i think his parents
called him the prince and he was treated
accordingly so this is a guy without any
problem of self-confidence computer
savvy from the start zuckerberg taught
himself the complicated computer
language c
plus and by ninth grade had created a
digital version of the board game risk
journalist jose antonio vargas
interviewed zuckerberg for his new
yorker magazine profile he actually
created a thing called zucknet
which is an internal instant messaging
system for the family so that computers
could talk to each other
and that's kind of the kid he was
[Music]
when he got sort of
tired of his local high school he
decided to go to exeter prep school
really because he just wanted more
challenge it was at the exclusive exeter
academy that zuckerberg and his friend
adam deangelo created a music website
called synapse it was intended to
anticipate what your preferences might
be
and it was very very popular even before
he started facebook he was fending off
offers from microsoft and others to buy
synapse for well over a million dollars
like a tech world version of an all-star
athlete big-name companies wanted to
recruit him right out of exeter again
zuckerberg was unimpressed and chose
instead to enter harvard in 2002
where it wasn't long before he got
himself in trouble
zuckerberg hacked into the school's
computers to collect images of students
nicholas carlson is deputy editor at
businessinsider.com
you can sort of tell that he's a little
bit of a troublemaker he creates
something called face mash his first
year in harvard and it's a sort of hot
or not for the harvard community and
then it maintained an entire list of
harvard students and which ones were the
most attractive ranking them by hotness
ellen mcgirt interviewed zuckerberg for
fast company magazine
face mash worked in kind of a a little
bit of an icky way it made people upset
obviously people felt mocked or exposed
and it was one of the first big
experiences that mark had with the
privacy issues of the masses
under pressure zuckerberg shut down the
site the harvard administration board
charged him with breaching security
violating copyrights and violating
individual privacy
but by then facemash was a campus
sensation zuckerberg had seen his future
at the same time getting trouble for the
building this mischievous web tool he
built a mischievous web tool that was
really popular i imagine that he had a
couple of sleepless nights worrying
about how how bad this thing was going
to be it was relieved when it all blew
over
but was also incredibly curious about
what he could then make next
if you're a genius with genius friends
sitting in a dorm room suddenly the
world looks like a big happy open place
if you can just get into that database
at the time the technology landscape was
changing dramatically
brad stone is a senior writer at
bloomberg businessweek the internet was
was really a much different world back
in 2004 friendster really demonstrates
that a social network needs to have
technical chops the site goes down all
the time it's unreliable myspace also
it's full of ads it's very distracting
it also begins to have technical
instability
at harvard zuckerberg met classmate and
future business partner eduardo saverin
author ben mesrick is one of the few to
have interviewed saverin about the early
days of facebook eduardo met mark
zuckerberg in an underground jewish
fraternity the underground scene at
harvard you know these were not really
fun events these were kind of strange
little social settings really bad
parties mostly all guys and so eduardo
and mark met in this scene
and they became friends pretty quickly
because they were both kind of outsiders
facemash got zuckerberg noticed by three
insiders upperclassmen building a social
networking site called harvard
connection olympic rowers and twins
cameron and tyler winklevoss with
partner divia narendra
harvard connection was an idea that i'd
come up with when i was a junior in
college which is at the end of 2002. the
team had been building the site for
nearly a year two of their original
programmers had moved on and they
desperately needed a new partner the
three of us are not computer programmers
by by trade or practice we did need an
actual programmer to to write the actual
hard lines of code and we thought mark
was that guy the trio reached out to
zuckerberg
he was enthused excited
and clearly his his eyes were lighting
up
what happened next sparked a furious
battle over how facebook was actually
created
the details unfold in email exchanges
between zuckerberg and the harvard
connection team
at first zuckerberg appeared eager
i read over all the stuff he sent and it
seems like it shouldn't take too long to
implement so we can talk about that
after i get all the basic functionality
up tomorrow night
then zuckerberg began to delay the
project
december 4th sorry i was unreachable
tonight i just got about three of your
missed calls i was working on a problem
set
december 10th the week has been pretty
busy thus far so i haven't gotten a
chance to do much work on the site or
even think about it really
zuckerberg was stalling because he was
busy working on a similar social
networking site based on harvard student
directory called the facebook
he and severan partnered to fund it mark
came to him and said you know you put up
a thousand dollars and we'll launch this
site and you know there were no
contracts these were just two kids in a
dorm room really
but that's where it started
writer nicholas carlson interviewed more
than a dozen people involved in the
founding of facebook and found instant
messages retrieved from zuckerberg's
computer he said zuckerberg sent to
saverin according to business insider
the im suggests zuckerberg was
deliberately misleading the winklevoss
twins he says things like look at this
site that i'm working on harvard
connection haha they made a mistake they
asked me to do it for them because i'm
working on my own facebook
we were always under the impression that
mark was working on
harvardconnection.com there was never an
indication from him that he could not do
the work
didn't want to do the work or was
working on something
identical on the side called
the facebook when he met with the
winklevoss brothers the last time he saw
that he probably should tell them that
he's been working on a competing product
he sort of conferred about it with
friends but in the end he said you know
what i'm gonna do i'm gonna blank them
i'm gonna blank them in the ear
on february 4th 2004 just as he was
expected to complete work on their site
zuckerberg and his friends instead
launched the facebook the winklevoss
brothers and narendra found out about it
the same way nearly everyone else at
harvard did it completely blindsided us
we
definitely did not expect that
mark wanted to have control over his own
project he saw that they were on to
something cool the winklevoss brothers
but he saw that he could do something
cooler and so
one he wanted to control his own thing
and two if he's going to go against
someone he's going to crush them and
that's what he did mark zuckerberg's new
harvard-based social networking site the
facebook was mired in controversy from
the start just days after he launched it
in february of 2004 the winklevoss twins
and divia narendra sent him a letter to
cease and desist in a nutshell our
complaint against mark zuckerberg is
fraud unjust enrichment and breach of
contract
zuckerberg responded with a letter
denying any wrongdoing claiming his site
was a separate venture and used none of
the same code
the winklevoss twins and narendra would
later appeal a 65 million dollar
settlement with facebook they lost in
federal court but that settlement could
now be worth 200 million dollars but
none of the vicious legal wrangling
slowed the incredible momentum of the
facebook
at that point my roommates were kind of
like you know this is pretty cool like i
bet this would work at other schools
so we launched it at columbia yale and
stanford and within a couple of weeks
each of those three schools
also like had thousands of users who
were like all right this is pretty sweet
like let's just go all out and see how
many schools we can launch the set as
quickly as possible about this point in
time
they started to take meetings with
venture capitalists and with bigger
advertisers and this is all kind of
eduardo's doing they got a pretty early
deal with
visa
and they had a deal with american
express
they had a number of advertisers that
came and went um
then record companies started getting
interested and they began to get some
pretty good revenue from the music
industry
enter sean parker who had his own
connection to the music business on a
trip to new york zuckerberg and his
partner eduardo saverin had dinner with
the 24 year old co-founder of napster
the seasoned entrepreneur and a truly
creative individual an extraordinarily
interesting person who had worked his
way into a network in the valley that is
just to die for it particularly at that
point
for zuckerberg parker was a hero and a
role model partner saverin didn't agree
eduardo did not think highly of sean
from the very beginning uh he thought
that sean was a snake oil salesman that
they didn't need sean
that sean talked a big game but was
living out of a duffel bag and had been
kicked out of two companies
in the summer of 2004 with severan
remaining on the east coast zuckerberg
left harvard
we came out to palo alto for this summer
just to hang out because palo alto is
kind of this mythical place where you
know all the startups come from and
got ready to launch at another 150
schools from the year started one of the
things that mark did that was very smart
by going to palo alto was to actually
enter the petri dish of
entrepreneurialism particularly for new
technologies
zuckerberg and his friends moved into a
large frame house with a swimming pool
and he reconnected with sean parker who
later became zuckerberg's roommate he
was the adult supervision he's the guy
who showed them how things are done in
silicon valley he's the one who showed
them how to meet investors
how to negotiate with them
who to hire mark has told me stories of
just all of the guys
coding late at night around dining room
tables and eating chicken mcnuggets and
cereal and there's partying going on
sean parker is bringing them around to
the different kind of
cool silicon valley hot spots and
meanwhile the website is is growing
astronomically fast i mean there's a
million member party by december of that
year
during this time
parker gave zuckerberg some shrewd
advice he took to heart he sort of
looked at him and said you need to be
the founder of this thing and you need
to be the ceo forever you know you can't
turn this over to investors and mark is
able to negotiate a series of
increasingly important investment deals
that do two things one allow him enough
operating cash to hire some of the
smartest engineers in the business and
to help him retain majority control in
the company
but tensions began to grow with
zuckerberg's original partner eduardo
saverin who remained on the east coast
eduardo felt that you know he was the
business head of the company and he was
no longer being treated that way uh you
know mark and sean were taking meetings
all over california they were meeting
with venture capitalists um and they
were kind of ignoring eduardo he
retaliated eduardo froze the bank
accounts to try and get mark's attention
and mark and sean began to sort of
figure out a way to build the company
without eduardo zuckerberg responded and
froze saverin out
eduardo was removed from the company
masthead and he essentially became a
non-entity he became a non-person he was
thrown out and he became very upset
facebook had a million active users on
college campuses nationwide and big
money was starting to pour in
sean parker the new president of
facebook introduced zuckerberg to
silicon valley angel investor peter
thiel who put five hundred thousand
dollars into the company then in the
spring of 2005 the venture capital firm
excel partners offered zuckerberg 12.7
million dollars for an 11 stake in the
company and didn't ask for much control
at all walking away from that investment
mark controlled three out of five board
seats which is a bizarre and
unprecedented situation to have one
individual
have absolute
effectively dictatorial control over the
disposition and direction of an
increasingly giant company overnight the
excel investment gave facebook a
valuation of 100 million dollars
as facebook's public profile grew so did
zuckerberg's control this time sean
parker was edged out in august of 2005
parker was arrested for suspicion of
cocaine possession although not formally
charged with a crime and immediately
released it led to his abrupt
resignation as president of facebook he
was the primary outside face of the
company and it was felt that somebody
who was under any kind of a cloud with
drugs
was not the right guy to be the public
face of facebook so mark reluctantly
agreed that he ought to leave facebook
was growing with remarkable speed and
zuckerberg moved the company from its
frat like house with the pool to a
larger and more conventional space in
downtown palo alto
but the college atmosphere remained the
same
one of the things that
i do focus on at facebook is
making sure that the culture is very
friendly you know and that people hang
out in terms of managing
this whole process
nothing you know nothing like i have no
idea what i'm doing you know
even their employee interviews were
different
chris kelly was brought on in the new
position of chief privacy officer to
deal with facebook's increasingly
contentious privacy issues at a time
when the entire company numbered only a
couple dozen employees the first time i
met mark we uh we climbed out on the
roof um out through the uh the window
and did our interview on the roof of
what was then a world wraps and it was
clear he was young but
he had a very sophisticated
understanding of what had happened so
far
and where he wanted to take the company
determined to keep facebook's unusual
creative culture alive all night
hackathons were one way to do it we have
these hackathons at the company right
where basically everyone gets together
um and just hacks on something and
builds something um all night long and
the only the only rule is that
you aren't allowed to work on at a
hackathon what you work on the rest of
the time so people work on crazy stuff
the hackathons were some of the most
kind of creative focus that you could
ever imagine in in a company imagining
these
incredibly talented engineers coming
together for a night
and saying we're going to stay up all
night and we're just going to program
and we're going to we're going to pick a
project
and we're going to get it done that
night it's like great make it we'll
prototype it and there'll be a prototype
war and see who wins it can be a
contentious environment
man they wouldn't be able to get all the
way across no i disagree that's [ __ ]
we had an argument from mark's point of
view this is where good ideas come from
quickly and efficiently
good ideas were flowing zuckerberg then
made a change that would give facebook a
sudden and dramatic boost allowing
people to identify or tag themselves and
their friends in photographs
that was
a huge huge change that led to massive
new use of facebook and photos became
very rapidly by far the most used part
of facebook and became the single
biggest driver of its growth
that growth continued in one direction
up according to facebook's internal
tracking its user base had shot to 5.5
million users in less than two years
and media giants were banging on the
door in 2006 yahoo baited the 22 year
old zuckerberg with an extraordinary
offer a buyout for one billion dollars
even more extraordinary zuckerberg
turned them down
now if you are a parent of someone about
mark's age
you're looking at the yahoo decision and
thinking
why did you not take that money
it's never been about money if it was it
would have just sold out we just felt
that doing that and going down that path
would not help us build facebook out to
what we thought it could be in 2006 mark
zuckerberg rejected a one billion dollar
pitch from yahoo when mtv pushed the
ante even higher michael j wolf was ceo
of mtv networks mark had taken me on a
walk around palo alto and showed me his
apartment
and afterwards we sat down for lunch
and i told him we'd be willing to pay as
much as a billion and a half dollars to
buy facebook outright his answer was
i think it's worth a lot more and
besides you've seen my apartment i don't
really need that kind of money and at
the same time
i may never have an idea as good as this
one so i'm not that interested in
selling there was internal strife around
it no question there were a lot of
people who wanted to sell ultimately you
know mark decided to turn down the
offers
zuckerberg wasn't ready to sell because
he had some ideas that he thought would
make facebook even more popular one of
them was called news feed a kind of
real-time wire service of updates about
what users were up to news feed is what
everybody is doing at that point or what
they're posting what they're linking to
the world that they live in which is
really what a newspaper is right it's a
living breathing newspaper of people
around you but many facebook users
thought that newspaper sent out too much
information and violated their privacy
750 000 of them launched an online
protest
to say that it was unpopular at first is
a dramatic understatement they were
under siege at the office they couldn't
leave they were surrounded by news
trucks almost 10 percent of our user
base at the time
joined the students against facebook
news feed group
zuckerberg was forced to apologize
he wrote his apology note himself
it was probably a good learning
experience
when facebook changed some of the
privacy controls it was an overstep i do
think he takes those seriously
but i do think that he's willing to
continue to overstep
for the for the purpose of making a
product that he wants to make the
apology was not a surrender zuckerberg
was sure that users would get used to
this new level of sharing and he turned
out to be right after tweaking news feed
it became one of the most popular
elements of the facebook experience
it just happened that the first time i
ever met mark was two days after that
happened
and i can tell you even though his
members were an open revolt he was not
the slightest bit flustered he had
complete confidence
that everything was going to work out
all right
zuckerberg decided it was time to take
facebook beyond its college roots and
introduce it to the general public
the response was stunning membership
doubled shooting up to 12 million by
2006.
zuckerberg radically altered the
facebook experience again when for the
first time the 23 year old ceo invited
programmers from around the world to
develop apps for facebook it was another
turning point expanding facebook from an
insular world of information to a
platform and it was like the gold rush
you open up this wonderful platform and
in comes every kind of developer with
every kind of idea from video sharing to
games to things that blink to things
that turned into you know ballerinas and
hippos and just every kind of fun
wonderful thing
the platform companies or the operating
system companies always do the best i
mean think of microsoft you know it had
this ubiquitous windows platform and all
these other companies wrote programs for
windows you know facebook's really
trying to create itself in that model
and in 2007 microsoft itself entered the
picture
this time with a deal zuckerberg
couldn't turn down and for the first
time the world got a glimpse of what
facebook may really be worth by the time
people were finally getting used to the
idea that anyone would pay a billion
dollars for facebook microsoft comes
along and pays
250 million dollars for 1.6
of the company it was outrageous it
valued the company at 15 billion
this took facebook from a thing that a
lot of people use to a thing that
everyone was talking about the 15
billion dollar company
but for a 15 billion dollar company
facebook was only making a meager 30
million dollars in profits to remedy
that zuckerberg announced a sweeping new
advertising system in the fall of 2007
one part of it let companies set up
their own facebook pages and advertise
using social ads lou kerner covers
social media and owns shares in facebook
social ads on facebook are ads where
they would say that your friends meg and
ryan like virgin america and it turns
out not surprisingly that when you see
that your friends like a product you're
more likely to click on that ad so
social ads have been very successful on
facebook virtually from the beginning
but another part of facebook's new
advertising plan beacon gave users far
more than they wanted and they let
zuckerberg know about it zuckerberg's
made a lot of mistakes the next mistake
which was a really big one was beacon
you go to a third-party e-commerce site
and you buy something and unless you
tell it not to really quickly it's going
to go back and tell all your friends
that you just bought a diamond
engagement ring and obviously you know
that sort of secret revealing can cause
a lot of trouble there was the the great
rallying cry that facebook ruined
christmas because suddenly everyone's
purchases were being broadcast to their
entire network
zuckerberg really tried to defend it for
a while it took him a while to realize
how wrong it was
on december 5th 2007 zuckerberg made
another apology he had overreached yet
again
but as with previous mistakes it
wouldn't really matter facebook was just
too popular and it wasn't long before
zuckerberg was loosening up the
network's privacy controls one more time
more than four years after co-founding
facebook zuckerberg still seemed uneasy
in the public spotlight
what's your next thing you're gonna do
get bought
none of these rumors are true right
um you know this is making me feel very
uncomfortable
by 2009 rumors were indeed swirling that
facebook would go public instead
zuckerberg took money from a new
investor
yuri milner ceo of the russian internet
investment firm digital sky technologies
offered a 200 million dollar deal for
just 1.9 of the company deals of that
size are kind of never easy there's a
lot of
back and forth this deal was about the
vision that we shared how big this
company can get
everything else was sort of secondary
milner's investment allowed facebook to
continue to expand and it kept the
development of the company firmly in the
hands of its founder zuckerberg knew
that pushing facebook advertising even
further was the key to continued growth
for years zuckerberg believed that
facebook was in a unique position
today even with the most advanced
advertising systems that exist they only
have estimates of what someone's gender
might be or what someone's age might be
or what they might be interested in but
on facebook we know exactly what gender
someone is and exactly how old they are
and exactly what they're interested in
jeremy smith is chief strategy officer
for second market a company that brokers
shares and privately held companies
which cannot yet be traded on the public
market
what makes facebook so desirable from
the perspective of advertisers
is that they are able to accumulate
information on their users like nobody
else the funny thing is the users don't
really view it as data it's themselves
it's their information it's their lives
that they're putting on there but as far
as advertisers are concerned it is the
the holy grail of data
pushing the boundaries of that holy
grail of data was about to get
zuckerberg in trouble again in december
2009 he revamped the privacy settings
for facebook's then 350 million users
unless users individually restored their
settings previously private information
was now available to everyone on the
internet many people just sort of took
that default and somewhat inadvertently
allowed a lot of their information to
become public
and and many privacy advocates believe
that they didn't explain that or
disclose it sufficiently
a firestorm of complaints from users and
consumer groups forced zuckerberg to
backtrack again sparking concerns in
congress
we are here today to urge facebook's
creator and ceo
mark zuckerberg to revisit this new
policy as soon as possible we believe
facebook should reverse its policy to
begin exploring guidelines so users know
upfront what's happening
adding fuel to the fire was the
surfacing of still more instant messages
business insider published messages they
said showed a friend asking then college
aged zuckerberg why people shared their
emails with him
zuckerberg's response was kurt and
profane you know i i mean i asked him
point blank about it and he was very
embarrassed
by them by the fact that he had sent
these ims less than one month later he
was put on the hot seat in a memorably
awkward interview at the all things
digital conference do you feel like
you're violating people's privacy
you know there were real learning points
and turning points along the way in
terms of
in terms of
building things
if i knew what i knew now then then i
hope i wouldn't have made those mistakes
but i can't go back and change the past
i can only do what we think is the right
thing going forward
you know anybody who's ever uh kind of
doubted what facebook is about or want
to question his integrity i mean they
can
they can keep pointing back to that
right to that instance of like i can't
trust that guy that is that is going to
be our check on him
for as long as he remains ceo you know
and in charge of that company it's going
to be like okay you're not that guy will
prove to us that you're not that guy
chris huffnoggle the director of privacy
programs at the university of california
berkeley believes mark zuckerberg
purposefully pushes the envelope on
privacy
in most situations where a company does
something that's unpopular they have
blow back they lose the ability to do
something but in facebook's case we have
something called i call blow forward
where
they take two steps forward there's some
type of public reaction and they just
take a little step back
and so over time they've been able to
open up profiles more and more
mark does not think you should be a
different person at work than you are at
the bowling alley
in bed at school
you know he basically thinks you should
be consistent across all these
environments so that's a very radical
view for many older people
by the time mark zuckerberg turned 25 in
2009 he had accumulated so much
notoriety wealth and power that author
ben mesrick had written a book about him
and the founding of facebook
this story started for me at an email i
received just out of the blue to my
website and eduardo severin was angry he
wanted to tell his story he had
co-founded facebook with mark zuckerberg
and then he said had been kicked out of
the company and he felt betrayed and he
wanted to talk savren talked to mesrick
for six months about a lawsuit he filed
against his former harvard classmate for
diluting severan's share of the company
according to mesrick facebook found out
eduardo was talking to him
and they essentially settled with
eduardo nobody knows for sure what
happened but what i've heard is he got
five percent of facebook and he had to
sign an agreement that said he would
never speak to ben mesrick again but
mesrick already had enough material for
his book my proposal had leaked out on
the web aaron sorkin saw it
scott rudin saw it so sorkin immediately
signed on to write the screenplay and
everything happened very quickly from
there
the pre-release publicity surrounding
the movie also seemed to force
zuckerberg to go on a pr offensive
the previously pressed shy zuckerberg
was suddenly everywhere if you build
something great that's what people care
about when people don't care about what
someone says about you in a movie he
gave oprah a tour of his house in 2010
and announced on her show a 100 million
donation to public schools in newark new
jersey 100 million
[Applause]
the social network opened in wide
release on october 1st 2010.
people want to go on the internet and
check out their friends so why not build
a website that offers that friends
pictures profiles i'm talking about
taking the entire social experience of
college and putting it online
zuckerberg complained about his
on-screen portrait as a ruthless
socially challenged power geek with no
friends he said there were factual
errors in the script
frame it as if the whole reason for
making facebook and building something
was because i
wanted to get girls or wanted to get
into some kind of social institution um
and i mean the reality for people who
know me is i've actually been dating the
same girl since before i started
facebook they just can't wrap their head
around the idea that someone might build
something because they like building
things
[Applause]
though he initially said he wouldn't see
the movie zuckerberg ended up taking his
entire staff to it he even showed up on
saturday night live you ever end up uh
seeing seeing the film that
the social network yeah i i did cool
thanks uh and uh what did you uh what'd
you think it was interesting
thank you to the hollywood farm press
for this extraordinary honor the social
network won a golden globe award for
best dramatic picture as well as three
academy awards
first tunisia now egypt what's next
but to an increasing number of people
around the world facebook wasn't just a
hollywood movie it was affecting real
life
in late 2010 demonstrators started
taking to the streets in tunisia and
later in egypt to protest their
repressive governments by this time more
than 70 percent of facebook's half a
billion plus users lived outside the
united states
in egypt one flash point for the anger
was a case of police brutality at the
center of the protests was a google
employee who ran a facebook page
whale gonam was the manager in egypt of
a page that was a memorial to this guy
who had been beaten tortured and killed
by the secret police
[Music]
and that group became very very large
many many hundreds of thousands of
members
during the period leading up to the
revolt against mubarak
[Music]
facebook expedited the ability of people
to express their dissatisfaction which
clearly sped up the process of these
revolts
the governments of tunisia and egypt
fell
protesters expressed their gratitude to
facebook on the streets
one named his newborn daughter facebook
and while gonim sang the social
networking sites praises on cnn i want
to meet mark zuckerberg one day and
thank him i'm talking on behalf of egypt
this revolution started on facebook when
hundreds of thousands of egyptians uh
started collaborating content you know
like we would post a video on on
facebook it would be shared by 50 000
people on their walls
within a few hours
facebook itself was was very quick to
try to distance themself from that
political activity i mean obviously they
supported it but they don't really want
to be seen as a tool of change because
obviously facebook wants to be active in
regimes like china they don't
necessarily
want themselves viewed as a tool of
insurgency
zuckerberg has taken on a personal goal
that might help him with his mission to
connect the world
he says he spends an hour a day studying
chinese which could potentially help him
gain a billion new friends
it's the fastest growing and the biggest
internet market in the world there are
hundreds of millions of users and his
mission is incomplete if he's not in
china mark zuckerberg's power had never
been greater and once again speculation
grew that he would take his company
public despite enormous pressure
zuckerberg has been hesitant to pull the
trigger and cash in 100 years 200 years
from now what's going to be more
important the money
right
or the fact that he has had this kind of
impact or the fact that he's you know
executed and developed and helped evolve
this thing that is more than just a
technology site and it's more than just
a website
and so i think that's why it's never
been about money and it's never been
about status when companies go public
it's a tremendous strain on the
management and in fact on top of all of
that
when you go public you you open yourself
up to even greater government scrutiny
aware of that scrutiny facebook has
amped up their presence in washington
with a team that includes several former
white house aides and influential
capitol hill insiders political official
after political official will tell you
if you are absent from the debate
you're likely to be the person who kind
of gets cut out
and so presence in that debate
particularly when you know google and
yahoo and microsoft and a number of
other very large players are spending a
lot on lobbying is a mistake
today
several facebook founders including
mark's friends and classmates have left
the company to start new ventures on
their own they've been dubbed the
facebook
mafia but much of silicon valley talent
is on their way in
top programmers are leaving companies
like google to be a part of zuckerberg's
momentum and facebook and google the two
internet behemoths are competing in
other ways ryan single is a staff writer
for wired magazine facebook and google's
relationship is pretty simple
they just don't like each other they're
really i mean they're competing cultures
um
you know facebook was sort of young
brash
wild and google is like you know an
algorithm company like these are guys
that like any problem there's got to be
a way that they can write a little
algorithm that'll fix it
it's clear that google missed the rise
of social and eric schmidt has has
admitted to to being flat-footed uh
around facebook and around social
they've tried a number of things most
spectacularly the buzz social network
that that just hasn't worked then in may
of 2011
facebook was embarrassed when it was
revealed that they had launched a secret
attack on google
facebook is doing damage control after
revelations it hired a pr firm to plant
negative stories about google facebook
claimed publicly it was not a smear
campaign but the exchange revealed just
how vicious the competition has become
the whole burst in marcello flap was was
really just an in-your-face expression
of the animosity that has sprung up not
only between these two companies but
almost the personal shakespearean drama
that's playing out between google and
between facebook which frankly has a lot
of former google execs who would like
nothing more than to supplant their
former company you can't underestimate
how driven mark zuckerberg really is he
says his mission is to you know make the
world more open a better place his
mission is also to be
number one right he wants to be
you know inscribed on granite above bill
gates i think he is well on his way like
gates another harvard dropout zuckerberg
is a fierce competitor he moved quickly
to vanquish rivals google and twitter
with a stunning acquisition in april
2012.
instagram is off the market in an
instant facebook likes the photo sharing
app so much it's paying 1 billion
dollars for it in cash and shares ahead
of its ipo but the app is free and has
little known revenue still facebook may
need instagram more than instagram needs
the money instagram has become a photo
sharing competitor and a social network
all its own it was considered a radical
and defensive move facebook cannot take
any chance that any other social network
oriented toward photos could really get
traction that would come you know
compare to theirs and i think so there's
a preemptive quality to this also i
think almost certainly google was
interested and probably maybe forced
facebook to act now
one month later facebook finally went
public in the largest ipo on record for
an internet company making mark
zuckerberg a multi-billionaire this is
an awesome moment
the ceo and hoodie and sneakers retain
tight control of his company with 57
percent of shareholder voting rights
facebook has literally changed the world
we've moved from the country to the
village to the town to facebook it's
just getting started too i think it's
just gonna get bigger and bigger and
bigger
for a site that's able to move from the
dorm room to a site where you know my 80
year old mother and myself and my
chiropractor and my third grade class
all reunites on the site and we all have
something to talk about
it's an achievement
zuckerberg is just
as visionary as steve jobs
he's going to prove just as influential
as bill gates
but he's not dealing with a piece of
gadget he's not dealing with some
program he's dealing with our lives he's
dealing with our identities so that's
why i think we're all going to have to
kind of keep him in check
in a way
we make decisions at facebook not
optimizing for you know what
is going to happen in the next year but
what's going to set us up to really be
in this world where every product
experience that you have is social and
that's all powered by facebook
it started as a simple question but
became one of silicon valley's great
success stories it's become in some ways
like the pulse of the internet
it's a siren for freedom we don't like
censorship we don't like being blocked
we think that the open exchange of
information can have a positive global
impact
a politician's bullhorn and a cyber red
carpet for celebrities reaching out to
their fans to be a successful startup
you need two fundamental things you need
great founders and you need a great
opportunity
blogging pioneer evan williams with biz
stone and original inventor jack dorsey
found that opportunity in twitter
which has grown to over 500 million
registered users who send over 55
million tweets per day
twitter presents a way to broadcast out
to the world
it has traveled everywhere but the
flight has not always been smooth
especially for the three in charge there
was tension at the company from the
beginning about how we turned the
enthusiasm for this very simple product
into revenue and profit
[Music]
welcome and hello we're here to talk
about twitter ow twtt
ah twitter
the product is a short burst of
information 140 characters or less
called a tweet
twitter was started by these three men
evan williams biz stone and jack dorsey
by july 2011 a round of funding valued
the company at eight billion dollars
tim o'reilly is a publisher and trend
spotter in the world of technology these
guys did something
not because they
knew exactly where it was going to go
but because they thought it was a good
thing in and of itself
those are i think often the real game
changers
twitter's co-founder is blogging
trailblazer evan williams the best and
worst of evan are two sides of the same
coin mike maples is the founder and
managing partner of the venture capital
firm floodgate an early investor in
twitter i think he's stubborn in the
pursuit of the ideas he cares about but
the thing that i've come to appreciate
over time is he is driven by that belief
the son of a farmer williams was born in
1972 and raised on the family farm near
clarks nebraska meg hurahan has known
williams since the late 90s he was the
third of four children
and his dad and his father like going
hunting
and evan's a vegan so i think that's
kind of the sense of how he fit in in
rural nebraska there's not a lot of soy
drinking
vegans on the farms near where he grew
up
so william's passion wasn't farming it
was web design and programming
after a year and a half at the
university of nebraska he dropped out
and drifted from various technology jobs
and startups
i started my first internet company in
nebraska in
1994
which required first explaining what the
internet was
o malek is the founder of technology
blog gigaom and has been writing about
the web for over a decade you don't go
to school to be an entrepreneur you
either have it or you don't right and f
seems to have it like you're born with
this the the skill to see opportunities
is innate it's in your dna and i think f
belongs to that category of people who
just know
what is happening
he took that entrepreneurial spirit west
to the mecca for technology geeks
northern california
his first job there was working for tim
o'reilly
he always had opinions about how things
could be better he wasn't satisfied with
the status quo ev was not shy about
letting us know what he thought wasn't
working and how we could do a better job
within a year williams moved on to
writing computer code as an independent
contractor for companies like intel and
hewlett-packard
in san francisco he teamed up with
software contractor meg hurahan
they became a couple and started a
company together
pyrolabs so this is my desk very messy
when we started pyra it was 1999 it was
right in the height of the com
boom it was a really exciting time to be
in in san francisco
product was a web program designed to
manage projects keep track of to-do
lists and assemble contacts
one small feature was a williams
invented tool to make it easy to update
an online personal journal at the time
known as a weblog and then as a joke
a friend of ours sort of decided he
wasn't going to call it web log he was
going to call it blog
williams saw a new product evan's really
good with names and branding and stuff
so we should call it blogger
blogger.com became a sensation
you really couldn't believe it you know
every day there would be more traffic on
the website more users signing up and
you would say well this has got to be it
can't possibly continue at this rate and
the next day there'd be more people ryan
single is a journalist covering the tech
industry nobody really knew what blogs
were right this was kind of a new thing
he had this idea you wanted an easy way
to publish online write an article write
something short about their lives and
publish it and this was this was a new
phenomenon blogging was this brilliant
additional layer that made it possible
for somebody to work just with the
content just with the images they didn't
have to do anything technical so it
really made the web the web for everyone
but the big idea from the small startup
wasn't enough to keep it afloat in fact
it hit an iceberg
the market crash of 2000 was disaster
for many in silicon valley
people were panicked.com started to fail
we weren't prepared for how quickly
everything would really kind of shut
down
we ran out of money
i left because i was tremendously
stressed and freaked out and like five
figures in debt and evan kind of closed
up shop and took the servers back to his
apartment and hunkered down to
to sort of ride out the storm the
post.com boom was was ugly in in san
francisco you had this whole
group of people who thought they were
getting on the train to riches so then
all of a sudden had to figure out what
exactly they wanted to do with their
life
williams posted to his blog that he was
now bloggers only employee
it went through some pretty dark times
and a lot of entrepreneurs would have
quit but ev stuck with it when you're a
great entrepreneur you have to you have
to be willing to try a few things and so
if you don't love it when you encounter
fierce resistance or stupidity or the
inertia that the world throws in front
of you you're going to give up you won't
persevere but if you truly love an idea
you'll be so convinced that you're right
and that the rest of the world is wrong
and just watch me that you'll just keep
plugging away at it and that'll be what
sustained you
evan williams was running blogger.com by
himself the company was struggling
barely surviving the dot-com bust
he had nothing but a great idea when he
got a call from an industry giant he
called his former partner meg hurahan
with the news he said are you sitting
down
and i said yeah he said no really are
you sitting down and i said yeah i'm
sitting he said
we've agreed to be acquired by google
the amount of the sale was never
disclosed
it's like playing in a double a league
and then all of a sudden you get a call
from the yankees and they're like you
know i want you to come play in the
playoffs
google was huge and they were cool and
they were going places that's gonna be
pretty amazing right i've hit the big
time
google was going places and williams was
going with them he went to work
developing blogger.com for the exploding
search giant during this time his future
business partner biz stone was three
thousand miles away on the east coast
working as a creative director at a
competing blogging website called
zanga.com
david kirkpatrick is an author and
commentator on technology and social
media this stone is an interesting guy
for silicon valley because he's a little
bit more of a insufficient
rebel type personality i think he's uh
he's very funny and acerbic and prone to
kind of gags
stone jumped on the blogging bandwagon
but grew frustrated with the direction
of zanga he moved to los angeles in 2001
and wrote two books on blogging for
stone google also came calling and hired
him to help them develop their new
acquisition blogger dot com
here's where twitter's two future
business partners first met
in 1999 evan and i were basically rival
had rival companies
and uh ev
sent me a note says how about you come
work here for me so the first time we
actually met was any when he picked me
up at the airport to take me to work
but their time at the company was
limited after less than two years at
google williams walked away in october
of 2004
he had never really gone to work for
anyone or worked at a company he's an
inventor he's an entrepreneur he wants
to be able to build the things that
occur to him when they occur to him
by the end of 2004 williams wrote a
business plan for a new internet startup
called audio a podcasting company that
would distribute and publish audio on
the web
he raised 5 million dollars from some of
the biggest names in angel money and
venture capital including google backer
ron conway lotus founder mitch kapoor
and his old boss o'reilly media chief
tim o'reilly ev having had a success
with blogger found it relatively easy to
raise angel money and vc money around
the idea that podcasting was going to
become a next generation of blogging
stone left google and joined williams at
odio but the young company suffered a
devastating blow odio hit a glass wall
named apple
mike maples invested 25 thousand dollars
in odio we were going to take podcasting
to the masses well a week after he gets
my check
apple gives podcasting away on itunes
and when you're giving podcasting away
and all of the playback devices are
ipods it's not clear there is a business
anymore
within six months of starting the
podcasting company audio evan williams
reputation as a silicon valley success
story was taking a hit
thanks to apple's itunes odio's web
music distribution venture was dead in
the water and by the end of 2005
everyone in silicon valley knew it i
didn't really think much of audio i just
didn't i thought the idea of a
podcasting company which is quite
marginal
while the company's prospects look dim
there was help on the horizon
enter jack dorsey
in 2005 dorsey was running his own
startup
a self-proclaimed computer geek as a kid
dorsey was obsessed with maps he
wallpapered his room with them you know
maps of transit systems street maps of
the city highway maps and then as his
family finally acquired a personal
computer he realized that he could
basically draw his own maps on the pc
as an adult his obsession evolved into
creating software systems for sending or
dispatching messages instantly for 911
emergency centers and couriers and taxis
and whatnot the concept that came out of
this was this very simple here's what
i'm doing anyone who's interested can
follow along in real time
for years dorsey had been looking to
explore the potential of a dispatch
system that could help friends stay
connected
after a chance encounter with williams
he thought he saw his opportunity at
that point i needed to get a real job
and write a resume and i'm a very low
level programmer and i've always loved
that that aspect but i wanted to do
something different and i had read about
ev from a successive blogger over lunch
at this children's playground dorsey
described the idea he had been carrying
around since he was a teenager the
simplest thing that we can do
is for me to be able to send out a
message from my phone
and have other people to be able to to
read it in real time
he pressed williams to let him try it
saying let's just do that it's
so simple to program we could do it
maybe in two days
williams gave him two weeks
dorsey asked biz stone to help develop
the graphics and visual elements
two weeks later they had something
we built a system to
immediately take a message so you could
have a 20 nokia phone
send a message that i'm in the middle of
central park in new york city watching
the geese pass by in the lake and it
would go out instantly to all your
friends in real time
on march 21st 2006 dorsey sent the first
message
the product worked but the friendship
dispatch system needed a catchier name
noah glass a co-founder of odio scoured
the oxford english dictionary and came
across twitter short bursts of
information or tweets from birds
it was the most perfect thing because
it's exactly what we were doing
williams bought out of odio forming a
new company which became twitter in
april of 2007
the move cost him two million dollars
effin said to me literally we just don't
think we have a business here and rather
than just spend all of your money and
try to come up with something new or
keep the plate spinning i'm just gonna
give you your money back and in fact a
lot of the people that i invested in
audio with took their money back and
chose not to invest in twitter and
twitter is the investment by the way
where if you passed on it it mocks you
every day evan williams was chairman of
the board bis stone was creative
director and the soft-spoken jack dorsey
was twitter's first ceo
ev thought about it for a while and
decided jack
would be the logical choice as ceo even
though he was had no experience in
anything but coding he was not a leader
in you know from his business experience
and so making him ceo was a little bit
of a of a gamble on evan williams park
[Music]
it was this music festival that helped
twitter really take off in 2007 at the
annual south by southwest music and
technology festival in austin texas
twitter broke out with the public
and the winner is you can check your
cell phones
twitter
[Music]
[Applause]
i would like to thank everyone and 140
characters left
and
[Music]
we rented two screens and we put them in
the hallways
and they would show
what people were saying about south by
southwest
when we saw twitter operating in the
wild for the first time at this festival
we witnessed people
moving together as one and we lifted
this idea out of a fun geeky festival
what if this were in other events around
the world
twitter had met its tipping point during
the festival usage tripled from twenty
thousand tweets a day to sixty thousand
tweets a day twitter just showed up in
the world at a time when there was a
demographic shift in how computing was
being used when computers were no longer
productivity tools but social tools that
enabled expression
it quickly became a vehicle for
sharing what am i reading now what am i
thinking now where am i now who am i
seeing now
but williams and his team weren't
prepared for how many people wanted to
share
as williams later told charlie rose we
had a terrible
first year and a half actually where the
site went down a lot and was slow a lot
and it took us a long time to get out of
that that almost and almost killed us i
think
there was internal tension in the
company dorsey was struggling as ceo he
didn't command respect because it was
very unclear what this product was for
for one thing so this ceo no experience
uh no real authority
because he really was working in a
company still controlled by evan
and a product that was crashing
constantly the only good thing was that
twitter was taking off like hotcakes
the pressure mounted
on october 16 2008 williams blogged that
the company needed a more focused
approach from a single leader original
inventor dorsey stepped down as ceo and
williams took over
jack was devastated because twitter
really represented the exact thing that
jack had been thinking about in some
ways for his whole life to be pushed out
was just devastating he took months and
months to recover from that
twitter found itself on everyone's radar
and that included one very interested
potential competitor
it was kind of looking like facebook was
gonna be
pushed off to the side
twitter was an international sensation
in one year alone subscribers to the
social networking and micro blogging
site grew more than a staggering
thirteen hundred percent
all the attention here on twitter what's
this attention
that got the attention of facebook's
mark zuckerberg
the sense i get is that
mark zuckerberg probably has a vision
for where he wants to take facebook and
he probably looked down the road
and saw twitter on that road to
achieving his vision
zuckerberg tried to acquire twitter
businessweek reported he had offered 500
million dollars worth of cash and
facebook stock which ceo evan williams
turned down
by 2008 users were posting 300 000
tweets per day
users that included oprah winfrey
and it didn't stop there
on oprah wasn't as important as the
state department asking twitter to not
go on its daily maintenance because the
iranian elections were being broadcast
on twitter
following allegations of fraud in the
2009 iranian election protesters took to
the streets
authorities in the country censored cell
phone messages newspapers and websites
that covered the increasingly violent
protests
eclipsing traditional and mainstream
news twitter became the outside world's
primary source for information on iran
we don't like censorship we don't like
being blocked we think that the open
exchange of information can have a
positive global impact we've always been
pro information sharing democratization
of information and you know more
information is better
by the end of 2009 the number of tweets
went up to two and a half million per
day but stephen colbert was not
impressed my guest tonight
is the co-founder of twitter why 140
characters was was texting too complex i
mean what
the limit on texts are 160 characters we
wanted to reserve a little bit of room
for a username and so we made it 140 and
standardized there and you'd be
surprised at the creativity
everybody was talking about twitter but
one big question still dogged the
founders how are you going to make money
you know it's like i don't think ab
williams and bistone could walk down the
street without somebody just sort of
whispering how are you going to make
money can you give us an outlook for the
rest of the year at twitter's first
developer conference in april of 2010
the twitter founders finally introduced
a plan for how the company might make
money
we expect the ad program to be the
promoted tweets that we're launching or
we just launched this week to certainly
be the largest part um in in a few
months but it's going to take a while to
ramp up promoted tweets
uh allow people to in a transparent way
put marketing messages in front of
people who who follow twitter streams
and it'll be interesting to see how it
works i think that the company knows
that it's a work in progress
on october 4th 2010 came the news that
evan williams was stepping down as ceo
of the company
twitter has grown to be huge and yet it
has yet to really prove itself as a
business
and i think that evan williams has not
really proven himself as the right ceo
to lead twitter replacing him as ceo
would be former chief operating officer
dick costello we're growing it at just a
ridiculous rate you know having been
having run a few other companies and and
having spent a couple years at google
the pace of growth that we see is just
you know i've never seen anything like
it to castello long time known quantity
in silicon valley the operations guy
even though he's chief executive officer
he's really still the operations guy
evan's uh he's an idea guy but he's not
a ceo kind of a guy williams said he
asked costello to take the job so he
could be completely focused on product
strategy
but the musical chairs and twitter's top
management continued in march of 2011
williams departure opened the door for
original inventor jack dorsey to return
to a major role taking over as executive
chairman dorsey tweeted he was thrilled
to get back to work at twitter it's
pretty obvious that innovation slowed
down over the last couple years
and you know while twitter did grow
dramatically it grew without changing
itself very much there was a problem
with twitter from the beginning
that while it was a really cool
technology nobody really knew what it
meant as a business
that is a problem that some degree has
dogged the company to this day but that
hasn't stopped the world's obsession
with twitter it's a dream come true for
narcissists but it's also a dream come
true for journalists celebrities media
people
brands anybody literally that wants to
reach a large public with a series of
messages twitter is having an impact on
world history there just aren't very
many companies that do that there's no
question that twitter is becoming part
of the fabric of our society a way that
people communicate a way that news is
disseminated
it's the twittering of birds that
communication that we don't really know
the meaning of
and yet it is profoundly important